the binomial theorem extends to a thing
called the multinomial theorem whereas
instead of taking a product of a sum of
two things you take the product of a sum
of K things to get the multinomial
theorem and what underlies it is a rule
that we're going to call the bookkeeper
rule and here's why
so the bookkeeper rule is about the
question of look at the word bookkeeper
and ask how many different ways are
there to scramble the letters in this
word that actually are distinguishable
the point being that the two O's are
indistinguishable so the order in which
they appear doesn't matter likewise the
three E's in the two K's well how do we
answer this question a simple way to do
it to begin with is to label all of the
indistinguishable letters with
subscripts to make them distinguishable
so I'm gonna put subscripts one and two
on the O's one and two on the KS and one
two and three on the YZ now all the ten
letters aren't distinguishable and if I
ask how many ways are there to permute
these ten letters the answer we know by
the product rule is sent by the
generalized product rule is simply 10
factorial now my strategy is going to be
to use the division rule to count the
number of patterns of the word of the
letters in the word with no subscripts
the way I'm going to do that is take one
of these subscript in words and erase
the subscript so I'm gonna map it to the
same permutation of letters with no
subscripts I've just done that here I've
taken an arbitrary permutation of the
subscripted word and then I've erased
the subscripts and consolidated the
letters and I wind up with this
permutation okay now if I want to count
the number of unscripted subscripted
permutations then I simply figure out
that this mapping is K - 1 and I'm gonna
then divide by k well how many to 1 is
it
well how many subscripted words map to
this given pattern the answer is the
subscripts on the O's don't matter so
there's two possible orders in which
those subscripts might appear subscripts
on the case don't matter there's two
possible orders in which those
subscripts might appear subscripts on
the YZ don't matter three possible
or three factorial possible orders that
the subscript Smita currently 'is the
net result is that with two O's two K's
in three E's the mapping is two
factorial by 2 factorial by 3 factorial
to 1 and that instantly gives us by the
division rule if the total number of
permutations of the letters in the word
bookkeeper is 10 factorial over 2
factorial times 2 factorial times 3
factorial more generally by the same
reasoning if I look at a sequence of n
letters of which n1 RA is in n/2 or B's
up through NK r zzzz then the number of
permutations of those letters with the
repeated A's B's and Z's is n factorial
divided by n1 factorial times n 2
factorial through NK factorial and this
formula occurs so often that it has a
name it's called a multinomial
coefficient in this format n over N 1
and 2 through NK you could start to say
n choose n 1 choose n to choose and K if
you're thinking about how we pronounce
the binomial coefficients the convention
is that the sum of the n eyes is
supposed to be equal to the numerator n
this is called a multinomial coefficient
so n factorial divided by this product
of factorials is written in somewhat
shorter notation without the factorials
as a multinomial coefficient binomial
coefficients by the way were special
case when we write and choose K if we
wrote it as a multinomial coefficient
you'd have to write it as n choose K and
then choose n minus K so we can apply
this to think about coefficient
coefficients in expanding things that
are more than binomials so let's look at
expanding a kwinto kwinto meal a sum of
five things EMST and Y and I raise that
to the seventh power so that means in
these products of seven of these terms
I'm looking at words of length seven
whose components are the letters EMS
T&Y and if I so if I multiplied this out
applying the distributive law I would
wind up with five to the seventh terms
each of one consisting of a permutation
of the letters e MST and Y and if I ask
what's the coefficient in that expansion
of the term e-m-s cubed T why it's
exactly the number of ways of permuting
these five letters a word of length
seven made out of these five letters
with three occurrences of s in other
words the coefficient of e M s Cube T Y
in this product is the number of ways of
rearranging the letters in this sequence
of seven it's the word systems which is
what we chose it to be rememberable how
many ways are there to rearrange the
letters in the word systems by the multi
node by the bookkeeper rule there are
seven choose one one three one one okay
let's do another example what's the
coefficient of B a cubed N squared if I
expand this trinomial B plus a plus n to
the sixth power
well now again I have three to the sixth
terms how many of them involve a be
three A's and two ends by the bookkeeper
rule it's the number of ways well it's
the number of ways of rearranging the
letters in the word banana and by the
bookkeeper rule that's six with
subscripts 1 3 and 2 more generally
where this is what the multinomial
theorem says if i look at the
coefficient of the term a product of X I
to the our eyes in an expansion of a K
moan of a Kano meal a sum of K distinct
variables raised to the nth power now
I've got if I expanded this out using
the distributive law without collecting
terms I'd have K to the N terms each of
which was a permutation of the x1
through XK s um with repeats and then if
I ask how many of those products of any
of these K variables have this many X
ones this many X
who's through it this many x RK is this
many X KS I'm asking again a bookkeeper
question and the answer is n choose R 1
R 2 through R K so now we're ready for
the record to state the general Momoa
multinomial formula if I take a sum of K
terms at K no meal to the nth power then
expressing it in concise notation it's
the sum over R 1 through our case
summing to n of the multinomial
coefficient n R 1 through our K times
this product of excise I'm not putting a
highlighted box around it because this
is not a formula which is particularly
important to memorize and it's clearly
all clogged up with subscripts but
nevertheless it's good to have sometimes
for the record and next week we will
continue with this theme about the
connection between counting and algebra
and in particular not only ordinary
polynomials as we've been looking at
here with a product of sums but in fact
infinite polynomials or infinite series
when we take up generating functions
next week